depuis deux ans au québec parmi toutes
les nouvelles infirmières diplômées 1600
ne travaille pas en soins infirmiers
mais c'est sans nouvelles diplômées qui
ne travaille pas ça représente 18% de la
relève en soins infirmiers et depuis
quatre ans les nouvelles infirmières qui
elle intègre le marché du travail sont
moins en moins nombreuses à choisir un
poste à temps plein voici les chiffres
en 2013 47 pour simple des nouvelles
infirmières ont décroché un poste à
temps plein soit environ 1300
infirmières l'an dernier seulement 19 %
des nouvelles recrues ont choisi une
charge à temps complet soit à peine 535
le ministre barrette donne l'exemple la
cité de la santé de laval qui a de la
difficulté à combler une quarantaine de
postes
et bien dites vous qu à laval c'est à
peine une nouvelle infirmière sur dix
qui choisit un poste à temps plein selon
syndicats bon nombre de nouvelles
infirmières refusent carrément les
postes parce qu'avec une charge à temps
plein ils ont l'obligation en plus de
faire du temps supplémentaire ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour les infirmières
qui choisissent des postes à temps
partiel ou encore des postes
occasionnels l'ordre des infirmières du
québec estime que la situation pourrait
aussi s'expliquer par le fait que la
formation de certaines nouvelles
diplômées ne correspond plus aux types
d'infirmières recherché mais peu importe
la raison
ce qui semble clair c'est que depuis au
moins deux ans le québec n'utilise pas
le plein potentiel de sa relève en soins
infirmiers
[Musique]